欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
同学们,这一节课我们来讲一下关于交易率怎么样去提升, 以及它要避开哪些坑, 首先我们来看一下这后台的这个截图, 它的交易率是由站内交易, 还有就是站外交易来进行决定的, 同时呢, 它有一个复购率跟支付总化率, 这个也是非常重要的指标, 那么复购率我们可以针对老客户的一些复购就可以了,
我们平时的一些
业务逼单呢, 或者是搞什么活动, 9月大处, 或者是
3月, 以及其他的一些节假日活动, 都可以增加老客户的复购, 来提升它的这个复购率, 支付转化率的话, 也就是跟我们的
旋盘, 以及订单之间的
一个转化, 那么这两个指标, 一个是旋盘的质量要更好, 第二个就是业务的
转化能力要提升, 这样的话我们整体的
支付转化率才会更高, 那么我们来看一下
交易率具体的提升方法
第一, 站卖交易额, 那么这个交易额其实只占
我们的10%, 也就是这里面的交易额
总金额的10%, 才能够被计算到这个
站内交易额里面, 来进行一个
提升
交易率的新级
交易率的新级, 最主要就是交易额影响的, 如果是你交易额
不达标的话, 那么你下面这些指标再高, 也很难
实现你这个交易额的新级的, 那么为什么我们要去想办法提升我们整体的交易额的新等级呢, 因为整个店铺
整个店铺绝大多数都是因为交易力不足, 导致新级
低, 导致这个新级低, 所以
从最难的, 唯独入手已经是去提升交易力
那么
交易率的新级越高, 那么就相当于省了广告费
老客户办单需要手续费是吧
也就是我们老客户去下一个单的时候, 是不是平难要扣一些手续费
那么如果我们把这些手续费不花, 那么是不是我们很有可能就是
需要花更多的自动车广告费去获得更多的客户
才能拿到更多的订单
才能有更多的交易额
是不是这里的方式
只不过是换种方式去
提升而已, 其实钱
还是要花了的
是吧
具体方法我们来看一下
第一个就是我们要提升寻盘的质量
促成更多的交易
第二个就是提升业务的转化技能
提升订单的转化率
因为
这里有一个支付转化率
寻盘到订单的一个
转化率
需要我们去
规范话数
以及提升业务的
开发技能
第三个就是充分发挥老客户的
交易实力, 也就是你有很多老客户, 那么你可以适当的搬一些线下的单
到线上
这个就是我们刚才说的
虽然说他要一点手续费, 但是如果你的薪级上来了
那么是不是你的广告费
就会有一定的节省
那么广告费节省了是不是
是不是一样可以降低成本
这个是一样的逻辑, 只不过是我们在思考的时候可能没有
按照这种思路去想, 所以就觉得
老客户办单都是
增加成本
并没有减少
其实他在自动车这个板块
也是可以帮我们
下降一些成本了
那么最后一个我们来
理解一个概念的坑
首先零星和
一星到两星的
流量层级差距
很大, 也就是你店铺可能是零星
跟一星两星的
流量的差距
是比较大的, 一星跟两星和三星到五星的流量层级的差距
也是很大的, 也就是你这里一到两星的
那个流量区别不是很大
一到两星跟三到五星的区别就很大
所以说如果你在
两星的时候那么你要尽量
跃迁到三星那么这个是一个流量层级的变化
如果你在零星的时候你至少要能拿到一星
就这两个零界点
非常的关键, 按照这种
实录去
提升你店铺的星级, 那么你的流量层级
至少能够上一个层级
最后一个就是一定要花点钱
也不要零星
我刚才说的这个
你要花点钱也不要
让它是零星
否则你的直动车成本很高, 也就是你这里的
班单的手续费
远远低于你这个直动车的成本
所以我们要去自己去衡量
你是要用手续费去
提升你的
交易力呢, 还是单独靠
自动车成本去
提升你的交易力呢
如果用手续费
的成本肯定是会比你自动车的成本更低的
所以一定要想办法
去做好
正确的选择
然后去
针对性的提升
那么我们这个交易力
就能够在
具体的时间内
完成他的目标
就能够
让我们的电货的星级更高
获取更多的流量
好了
这节课我们就先讲到这里
下节课
我们再见